another I just feel like crowd-pleasing
performance and I I loved how kind of
emotional and you could tell how touched
you were by the crowd's response I mean
sort of walk us through how it felt
right after that dance it's always a
shock to me when people explode like
that when an audience explodes
I know what I bring and I know that we
brought fire so we want them to explode
but when you when they do it you're like
wow you you got what we were trying to
give you and so for the people in this
ballroom and for the people at home who
are watching and cheering baby we feel
it so yeah I guess I did I was like oh
my God but it's it's special
yeah exactly it feels amazing because
what we felt we kind of translated to
the audience and made them feel what we
felt at that particular moment that one
minute and 30 seconds and then they
stood up and they were like the whole
Ballroom yeah turned out they were
screaming and I was like wow that was it
that's it that's that is a perfect score
for us yeah
um you know I love it feels like week
after week you're improving and how are
you gonna what are you gonna do next
week at semifinals in order to secure
your spot in the finale well baby if you
thought it was hot now we're about to
really turn up the heat it might be fall
going into winter but maybe it's been
real summer in this Ballroom we want to
give we were the Spice Girls tonight but
it's gonna be even more spicy going
forward we just want to give something
that makes people feel like wow they
came they showed up they put in the work
and they turned it
um also last I can't remember if it was
last season of the Season before that
but you were partnered with a spice girl
did you guys get a chance to talk to
Melanie C get any advice or do you feel
like you have a bit of an edge because
you knew a Spice Girl well I danced with
Mel C and uh we didn't go that far
actually last season
um and we didn't have a chance to do the
samba but I was so grateful to actually
get a song from Spice Girls because I
have direct connection with her and with
Spice Girls and shangelo turned it I'm
so proud and we put on the great show so
yeah we didn't get to talk to a Spice
Girl directly but trust me the spirit of
the Spice Girls was in this Ballroom
tonight and I'm such a fan of the Spice
Girls every single one of them like
growing up in the 90s like baby Two
Become One wannabe mama look all the
sunflowers girl power so we were feeling
the spice tonight